can I bring you some breaking news now
there have been three explosions heard
in the Ukrainian Capital Kiev let's
bring in Muhammad Jam Jun he's in the
city Muhammad tell us what's happening
there
well Laura let me tell you first what
we're hearing uh as far as from local
officials the mayor of key Vitale
Klitschko um has posted some information
on his Twitter account and his telegram
Channel and he's saying that these
explosions happened in the chefchenko
district he also posted a statement
saying that as a result of these drone
attacks a fire broke out in a
non-residential building in that
District fire departments are working
several residential buildings were
damaged Medics are on the spot we're
clarifying the information about the
victims the chefchenko district which is
in central Kiev this is a district that
was also hit last Monday when Russians
started attacking Kiev again attacking
Kiev again after months of relative calm
this is a part of town where there are
administrative offices there are
educational institutions there are
residences our team here heard the first
explosion just about an hour ago since
then we have heard more more and we're
trying to clarify exactly what happened
the office of President Vladimir
zielinski has said that these attacks
were carried out by kamikaze drones a
lot of concern here right now about if
the attacks will continue throughout the
morning our team like many others here
we are taking shelter the air raid siren
started ringing out we've not been given
the all clear yet uh certainly a lot of
residents here on edge about what
exactly is to happen next and if attacks
will continue throughout the day Laura
okay Muhammad thanks very much for that
update from McCabe we'll come back to
you to get more on those explosions that
we've heard in the past hour in the
capital of Ukraine in Kiev